سأقول بصراحة
أن الغالبية العظمى من الأشخاص الذين
أتعامل معهم
كانوا طيبين للغاية ، لقد كانوا داعمين للغاية ، وهم
يعلمون أنني عملت في هذا العمل ،
ولا أريد أن أختنق هنا
ولكني عملت في هذا العمل من أجل  على مدار 40
عامًا لم أواجه أي مشكلات تتعلق بالسلامة في
حياتي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ولكن ما لديك هو مجموعة معينة من
المتقاضين
وأيًا كان موقفهم
جيدًا ، فإن الأشخاص الذين من المحتمل أن
يكونوا مهملين ليس لديهم  المال
والأشخاص الذين لديهم المال ليسوا
مهملين
ولكننا لن ندع ذلك يمنعنا
من القيام بما نحتاج إلى القيام به فيما
يتعلق بالتقاضي ، لذلك لدينا أشخاص
يفترضون أن الناس يعتقدون أن جيوبنا العميقة
تعيش في مكانهم
ستكون قادرًا على توضيح سبب مقاضاة الأشخاص إذا كنت
لن تحصل على المال ، وهذا
ما تفعله من أجل
[موسيقى]
عندما يقوم شخص ما تتمثل مهمته في ضمان
سلامة السلاح في
تسليم شخص آخر تتمثل وظيفته في  تكون
الطبقة الثانوية للحماية  من أجل
سلامة السلاح وهم يسلمونك
هذا الحق لي ويصرحون أن هذا
السلاح آمن ،
هذه هي الطريقة التي أمضيت بها حياتي كلها
ولكن طوال مسيرتي المهنية دون وقوع حوادث ،
لقد اعتمدت على خبراء السلامة
هناك لإعلان الخير
أبدًا  واجهت مشكلة الآن حدث هذا
وبالطبع
هذا أعني لي أحيانًا أنه أمر
سريالي جدًا حتى أعرف ماذا أقول
قتل ، لقد غيرت حياتي
فقط من حيث وظيفة الأسلحة
في الأفلام
والتلفزيون وظيفة
إجراءات السلامة التي سنضطر
جميعًا إلى معالجتها في النهاية ، ربما كانت على
الأرجح تقضي على
جميع الأسلحة الحية تقريبًا وطلقات إطلاق النار
و  الانفجار